come on tired of sinking your devices
not hipster enough for vinyl so where do
you go for music streaming music
services like beasts Spotify and Pandora
let users access millions of songs but
which one is right for you think of each
service like the kind of car you might
buy option one Pandora it's like the
Mercedes s-class so high-tech it almost
drives itself choose Frank Sinatra and
it will pump out music by old blue eyes
as well as rosemary clooney and neck and
Cole pandora is free but you'll hear
some ads shop so calm don't want the ads
that's gonna cost you four dollars a
month the limited library and you can't
always hear the song you want on demand
for that go to Spotify I call it the
McLaren of streaming music sites it's
high-profile it's flashing and it's
really powerful but do you really need
that much car if your music and tech
freak maybe you do it has a killer
catalog and incredible sharing features
Spotify free service comes with
commercials but do yourself a favor pay
them the ten dollars a month lose the
commercials and you can listen while
you're not connected to the Internet
but if you want it all you might want to
go with these music it's like a Ferrari
FF it could go from zero to 100 in about
four seconds and fit a car seat in the
back you don't even have to pick an
artist or a song you can make a playlist
by using beaches version of Mad Libs now
this doesn't have a free option it's
fifteen dollars a month for five
accounts or ten bucks for one nobody
said blending style and substance comes
cheap
you